-I'm so happy that you're here.
-Me too. Very excited.
-I'm a fan.
It's your first time
on our show.
-Yes.
-I want to get to know you.
I want to ask you -- you're
from Cuba, is that correct?
-Yeah.
-And did you start acting there?
-I did.
I went to drama school
when I was 14.
That was like, four years
of theater school.
-Yeah.
-And when I was on my second
year, I did my first movie.
I auditioned for it
and I got it,
and the teachers
were not very happy
and they told me
if I did the movie,
I was going to --
[ Clicks tongue ]
get kicked out of school.
-Of acting school?
-Yeah, because, you know...
-Wait.
This is kind of the goal, right?
-Well, if you do a movie,
you're not going to school.
So...
-I understand, yeah.
-I still did it, though.
-That's right.
Look at you now.
Come on. Yeah, exactly right.
[ Applause ]
-So they made me repeat
the year.
-Oh, really? They did?
-It was worth it.
-Yeah. Oh, good. Yeah.
I also heard something that you
used to hitchhike to school.
-Yeah. Didn't you?
-No. No. That's very dangerous.
I don't hitchhike.
-No, it's not in Cuba.
I mean, you just get there
faster than just --
-I understand, yeah, but...
-I will get there faster
than you, maybe.
-Yes, you will. Yeah.
Because no one
would pick me up.
If we're both on the street
with our thumb out,
they're gonna pick you up
and not me.
-Well, I didn't
do the thumb thing.
I'd just go to the stoplight,
so the cars have to stop.
-You would just jump
into strangers' cars,
like, "Take me to school"?
-Pretty much.
-Yeah?
-You just go to the window.
I'm like, "Hey, can you go
to the next stoplight?"
-No, this is too dangerous.
Oh, no, no.
-No, it's not. I mean,
everyone's very used to it.
It's like free carpool.
[ Laughter ]
So.
-Any children watching,
don't do this.
But is that how you
ended up in the Bond movie?
Because you're from --
No, no, no! Not hitchhiking.
No, not hitchhiking.
Being from Cuba, sorry.
-"Hey."
-"Hi, do you guys mind
if I'm in this movie?"
-"Do you go to London?"
-"Can I be in the new
007 movie?"
"Sure. Come on."
No, but is it
because you're from Cuba?
Is that how?
-I mean, something
to do with that.
I think...
-You're so good in this,
by the way.
I told you backstage,
but I really mean it.
-Thank you.
-You get a giant laugh.
I'm not going to spoil
anything for anyone.
I won't ever do that.
But, dude.
This one scene,
it's just beautiful to look at.
I go, it's iconic.
-Thank you very much.
-What you did, you crushed it.
You're fantastic.
-Thank you. Thank you.
-Do you want to describe
who you play? Your 00 agent?
-Yeah, I play Paloma.
She's a CIA agent in Cuba.
She's there to assist Bond
in his mission.
And she very excited
about the job.
-Yeah, yeah. You really are.
-She's very, very happy,
and like, you know, also nervous
because it's her first job,
big, big job.
-Yeah, you're like --
I could say the line.
-What line?
-You're like, "Oh,
I'm only three weeks
in training on the job."
-Yeah, yeah, exactly.
-Yeah.
-The funny thing is that
I also had only
three weeks' training, so.
[ Laughter ]
I think I just kept saying it
so much that Cary was like,
"Just say it. It's fine."
-Oh, because that's real life.
-"Just keep it."
-You just came from doing
a Marilyn Monroe movie
right to this.
-Yeah.
-Was that difficult, to go
from that extreme to this?
-Yeah. Well...yeah.
-Yeah.
-I mean,
Marilyn did not train at all.
-No. Yeah, no.
-Like Paloma.
I mean, it was, it's like
opposite things, you know?
I did Marilyn,
it was very intense,
and then I finished shooting
on a Friday.
I got on a plane on a Saturday
and I started shooting Bond
on Monday.
So I just remember
being on set like,
my first scene and I kind of
like started whispering
and Cary was like, "Mmm.
No, we're here now."
-"You're in this movie now."
-This movie now.
-[ As Marilyn Monroe ]
"Happy birthday."
"No, we're not doing that now.
We're doing this."
-Kind of.
-We're doing this movie now.
Daniel Craig.
You guys are great together.
Is it odd that
you were in "Knives Out"
and then you're with Bond?
You guys are
a traveling team now.
-[ Laughing ]
-You go together.
-Yeah, that was awesome.
I mean, "Knives Out,"
it was such a special movie.
We had so much fun,
and Daniel and I
were together all the time.
We were this team.
But back then,
only Daniel was talking
about Bond and his training.
I had no idea what was
going to happen.
-That you were gonna be in it?
-No, no.
That happened,
like, four months later.
-He's phenomenal, man.
-It was a very happy
coincidence.
-I loved the movie
top to bottom.
I'm a big fan of all the movies,
but this one has everything
you could even think about.
Action, you know,
suspense, spy thriller thing,
love story.
-Humor.
It's emotional,
but also it's real stunts.
It's not just like a CGI thing,
which, you know, is fine.
This is like, real
human beings doing crazy stunts.
You're like, "What?"
I've never seen anything like
that one motorcycle thing.
-It is spectacular, really.
-It's a movie.
It's just like, wow, they made
an unbelievable movie.
-You really like it.
-I loved it.
I loved it. You were so good.
I want to show everyone
a clip from the movie.
Here's Ana de Armas in
"No Time to Die." Take a look.
♪♪
[ Gunfire ]
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's what I'm talking about!
That is what I'm talking about!
That exact scene!
You're amazing.
Ana de Armas!
Here's how it works.
We have nine mystery boxes
containing objects
no one has ever seen before.
On your turn, you pick a box,
take out an object,
and describe it
to your opponent.
Then they have to guess
if you're lying
or telling the truth.
We'll play three rounds.
[ Light laughter ]
[ Deep voice ] Ana, why don't
you pick the first box?
-Of course.
-Number 5!
-Oh.
-8!
-5!
[ Audience shouting ]
-I can't hear anything.
-No, you can't hear.
Now they're yelling
every number.
Yeah, they're just...
[ Audience shouting ]
Yeah. They li-- 5's a --
Okay. Oh, this could be acting
right now.
I don't know if it's heavy.
-Doing this with heels
is not good.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright. Now, you open it,
and then you place it out here
so that the audience can see.
And the lying begins now --
or the truth telling begins now.
Here's where the game becomes...
-Okay.
-...exciting.
[ Light laughter ]
What?
This is very creepy.
Don't look.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm not looking.
I can't see it.
-Who thinks of these things?
-Wha-- Who thinks --
are you asking --
Yeah. Okay.
-What to put in these boxes?
-Yeah.
-Okay.
-All right.
Describe, describe.
-Wow.
-What?
What is in --
What is in box number 5?
-Oh, my gosh.
So...this is a --
-You're lying.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, wait.
-The -- So maybe
I don't know how to say
something in English, so...
-Okay.
-You know.
-Is it "pumpkin"?
-Okay, that sounds about right.
Topical.
-Okay.
With three people taking --
it's like a Jacuzzi pumpkin.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I just want to hear you say
"Jacuzzi pumpkin,"
like, forever, like...
"It's a Jacuzzi pumpkin."
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
[ Both laugh ]
-Okay.
-Gonna get better.
-Alright.
So, is there three people
in the pumpkin?
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
What?
-Ah! In the Jacuzzi.
[ Laughter ]
-Uh-huh.
-Okay.
One is...
[ Laughter ]
I really don't know
who these people are, but...
[ Laughter ]
-You should know them.
-They're -- They're...
[ Both chuckle ]
...murderers.
[ Laughter ]
They're, like, bad people.
-Oh, oh.
-This is bad people.
-Okay.
These are three murderers
in a pumpkin hot tub.
[ Laughter ]
Now, if this is a lie,
then I will give you
a million dollars.
There's no way you can be
making this up.
-Wait.
-I'm gonna say -- There's more?
-Smells good.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
I'm going to say...
Ana de Armas...
[ Laughter ]
...you are telling the truth.
[ Clears throat ]
-You sure?
[ Light laughter ]
-Yes.
-God damn it.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Did I -- Let me see it.
[ Bell dings ]
-Who are these guys?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, yeah. You don't know them?
Oh, no, that's -- that's...
[ Both laugh ]
Yeah, that's from "Halloween."
That is Jar Jar Binks.
-This is "Friday the 13th,"
isn't it?
-That's "Friday the 13th."
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-I don't know what that is.
-Yeah.
I don't know why he's --
he's drinking in a Jacu--
[ Light laughter ]
-Looks like a shrimp to me.
-No, that's not a shrimp.
It's -- It's from
a "Star Wars" movie.
-Oh.
-A shrimp.
It's Jar Jar -- Oh, yeah.
-I don't know.
-Good. Alright. Here.
You can put that right here.
-Okay.
-Alright.
Which number shall I...?
-3!
[ Audience shouting ]
-I heard a 3.
I heard a confident 3.
And here we go.
[ Grunting ]
-You're so bad.
-Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
It's so heavy. Oh, my gosh.
[ Both chuckle ]
♪ La, la-la, la-la ♪
[ Vocalizing ]
[ Humming ]
-It's very tempting.
Like, I want to...
-Yeah, I --
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
I get it.
It's a lot -- It's --
It's a box inside of a box.
And in there is a --
it's a bunch of butter knives
with a cable-knit sweater
over --
a tiny sweater over it.
I'm assuming this is
a Chris Evans reference.
[ Laughter ]
And it's --
a sweater over a bunch
of knives, butter knives.
♪♪
-What? No.
[ Laughter ]
-I wish I could --
-So, that's a Chris Evans
reference,
and you just went
and picked that one out?
That's very strange.
So, you knew
that that was there.
-Well, we knew that you were
gonna be on the show, so, yeah.
♪♪
You're in "Knives Out."
-No, I remember that.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Yeah.
So they probably thought
that you would get it,
I'm assuming.
And then you would
have to laugh
and think of your memories
from being with Chris on set.
-I think you're also telling
the truth,
because you just said it,
like, very fast.
And, like...
-I wish it was funnier.
-Yeah, it's not that funny.
-No, it's pretty serious.
[ Light laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Think I'm telling the truth?
-Telling the truth.
-I'm lying.
-No, you're not!
-Yes. It's a "Marriage Story"
lunch box.
-Oh, my God.
[ Buzzer ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Spinning Adam Dri--
[ Laughter ]
They're arguing.
-God damn it! Okay.
-Scarlett Johansson
and Adam Driver
are arguing with each other,
spinning around --
-I can see. Yeah.
-It's a music box.
Thank you. Hey.
That was some good acting,
I thought.
-That was so fast.
-That was quick thinking.
I thought -- Yeah, thank you.
I know.
Alright, here we go.
This one's for all the marbles.
Ana, this one's
for 10,000 points.
[ Audience shouting ]
[ Shouting continues ]
Oh.
Controversial choice.
I would have went with 7,
myself.
-This one's very light.
Very light.
-Oh, okay, very light.
Why would you do that?
Oh, maybe --
-Just to show you.
-Yeah.
But maybe you're -- No?
-I don't know.
-Okay, I don't know either.
It's very tricky.
-Why is this...
[ Laughter ]
What is this?
-If it's another pumpkin
with murderers in it...
[ Laughter ]
-No, it's -- it's --
♪♪
-I don't --
You're making a fa--
I have no idea what it is.
You're --
-Well, trust me,
this is very strange.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Ana, just take a breath...
-Okay.
-...and describe what you see.
♪♪
-Okay. So...
-[ Chuckles ]
-It's a turtle.
"Turtle"?
-Yeah.
-Okay.
-Turtle.
-Did I -- Turtle.
-Tur-- Tur-- Turtle.
-Tur-- Turtle.
-Turtle --
Oh, it's a turtle, okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, but instead of a...
-Shell?
-...shell...
-Uh-huh.
-...it's a hamburger.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Like, they dressed the --
The -- The turtle lives
in the burger.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-"The turtle lives
in the burger" is so great.
-It would be a turtle burger.
-It's a turtle burger.
The turtle lives in the burger.
It's almost like
an acting exercise.
-It's on top of --
-"The turtle lives in
the burger. The turtle --
Okay, and let's yell, 'Action.'"
-Yeah.
-So, it's a turtle
inside of a burger.
-The shell is the burger.
-The shell is a burger.
-Yeah.
-That sounds like something
our props department would do.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-But I'm not smelling
any hamburger.
[ Light laughter ]
And I got to use all
my senses here, with this game.
-You didn't smell the Jacuzzi,
either.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Laughing ]
That's true that I did not...
♪♪
-Ah. Ah.
-[ Laughs ]
-That might have been
a little give there.
You were like...
[ Light laughter ]
Why would you do that
if you were telling the truth?
Which means...
[ Both laugh ]
...Ana de Armas...
you lie!
[ Laughter ]
Let me see.
-Oh, come on! This is --
-Oh, my gosh! I did it again?!
[ Bell dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Both laugh ]
Finally, I did really good.
Wow!
-What is that?
-That was a good --
Turtle burger was good!
I like turtle burger.
We're going to put that
in the next game,
by the way, in honor of you!
Ana de Armas, everybody!